Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Shadows 2.
Now, this indie horror game just came out yesterday, it's very recent, but it's already getting good reviews.
Not that I know what it's about because I've never played Shadows 1.
But I always play things out of order, "because that's how Markiplier do." - Markiplier 2016
So, it's apparently past midnight at the office.
Wonder what's gonna happen (probably rainbows and sunshine)
Ohh. Oh, it's got camera. Woah.
What was that?... It was a book flying across the room.
Ohhkay. Aaaah.
For a second there I thought it was gonna be like, Five Nights at Freddy's style,
but it doesn't look like that may be it.
Ohhkay...
Aaahhhh.
Uh-oh.
Wait, does that make me a security guard,
or was I just weirdly looking at the security cameras?
Why am I at an office alone?
"Open inventory..."
"You can enable/disable object hints in the options"
Aww, cool!
"Personal notes"
*reads*
Hey! I'll be the judge of that,
you don't let me tell me who be scared.
Alright.
So- "Switch flashlight mode"?
Ohhhhh!
Ooh, it's got a brightness setting,
COOL!
Is that gonna drain the batteries faster?
Maybe.
Hellow.
Aaaaahhhh.
See, I'm really glad that I kinda branched out back into doing these indie horror games,
because number one, you never know what you're gonna get.
I mean, a lot of these indie horror games, they kinda go on the jumpscare trope,
but, occasionally, you'll come across an interesting little game
that has a, y'know, it has a premise,
and it has, a story,
and it has an environment.
These are all generic things that I'm saying, but I'm trying to...
be intellectual about what I'm saying
but you never know what you're gonna get  once you go into it
so you can see-
Uh-oh.
Oh, well why is this blocked off?
Hello?
Can I move this?
Thank you.
*gasp*
What was THAT?
What WAS that?
Hello, "I don't think I want to go there."
I WANNA GO THERE!
I'M AN IDIOT!
I RUN FACE-FIRST INTO DANGER!
I wanna give it a big ol' kiss.
♫ Come out, come out, wherever you are, ♫
♫ Marky's gonna get you ♫
Oh!
*reads*
What does that mean?!
How-
How much could you forget that you need to write things down
to remember how to get out of the building when you're bored?
Well, that's bizarre.
Anyway,
thanks, boob-eye lady for that
*mutters*
handy hint.
Was there something down there?
No...
Alright.
"Try the other corridor and go right..."
(Softly) Well, I don't know about that...
There we go!
How about I just stop being a big bitch and just go down the corridor,
that would be good...
Hello?
♫ Come out, come out, wherever- ♫
Oooh- WOAH, hey, woah, woah, WOAH, WOAAAHHH
WHAT AM I LOOKING AT?
Something? Huh?
You don't wanna mess with me...
Huh?
*gasp*
"There's no power."
Well, that's a problem.
Hmmm,
Seems like there might be a
MONSTER
around here...
Something that wants to mess with me...
Hm?
*spook*
Oh!
Hello!
What the hell?
WOAH!
Why am I back here?
What the FUCK happened?
Wait, what happened?
What, did I die?
WHAT HAPPENED?!
What's that...?
Ohh...
Hey, WAIT A MINUTE!
Woah, wait a minute, "What the hell?"
Oh, my question exactly,
What the hell just happened?
How did I get back there?
Oh, no, you do NOT!
Ohhh.
Well,
♫ Come out, come out, wherever- ♫
OH,
really?
Ahhh..
♫ Marky's gonna- ♫
*JUMPSCARE* A FF-!!!!!  *spoopified*
OK! We're fine, nothing happened!
Nothing actually happened!
Ok, alright,
we're fine, everything's cool-
Woaaaaahh
What, the fuck, was that?
Woahkay!
Woaaah, I can't move!
Huwhaatt?
What happened?
What happened? x2
I don't know what happened!
What?
*reads*
Ohkay,
well the- What happened?!
I'm so confused!
Do I go back?
What the hell happened?
Woaahhh...
Alright.
Oh, man...
This kinda reminds me of The Stanley Parable in it's layout, by the way,
just wanted to say that...
So there was something over here...
Oh, now there's nothing over here, huh...
Alright...
Wait, is there power now?
*ding*
Oh,
there's power NOW,
I wouldn't have tried tha-
*gasp*
oh, goddammit,
it was just the door closing,
I'm such a frickin' idiot, goddammit,
getting spooped by a door...
Ok, why am I going to floor 9?
What's here in floor 9?
*reads*
Well, I have a funny feeling that bad stuff has already happened with you, bub,
but you don't need to worry 'bout that at all,
because
I got yo back.
Well,
♫ Come out, come out, wherever you are! ♫
*kerchunk*
Alright,
♫ Marky's gonna find you... ♫
Ooh...
This looks familiar...
*reads*
Well, that's a good stratejum...
Alrighty then...
*creeeaaaakkk*
WHO'S OVER THERE?!
HUHH?!
What was that...?
Did you hear that?
I heard that...
Why does it seem like exactly the same layout as the other place?
Seems like exactly the same layout-
Either someone is dicking with me,
or this is
laaaaaaazy
level design.
I don't know which.
Oooooh..
*reads while chuckling*
Ohhh,
good observation there,
buddy.
Oh, you're such a keen observer.
Ohkay,
so this must unlock...
this over here...
Hellow?
*kerchunk*
No?
Maybe I gotta uuuuuse it?
No,
I don't have anything in my inventory!
What?
That doesn't make any goddamn sense,
but I picked up a key...
I definitely did pick up a key...
I'm a hundred percent sure that that's actuall-
Woah.
*raises voice while reading*
Let me just put that down,
I don't need to learn about a goddamn thing,
do I?
Ohkay...
So what happened to the key that I had?
OH!
Ohkay, so I needed the TV remote.
Why do I need that?
That doesn't seem like a break that I should take
in the middle of this endeavor...
Alright, here we go anyway.
Ahh...
[static]
"Emergency Action Notification", ok...
Why?
[static]
How does this affect me?
[We interrupt this program.]
[This is a national emergency.]
[Important instructions will follow.]
*shut down*
Ohhhhh.... *door creaks open*
Oh- Woaaaaahhhhh
Ohhhh
What door opened?
Ohkay..
Let's see..
*reads*
BRUH
UGH I'M SO SCARED
Alright, did this one open?
Yes, it did.
♫ Come out, come out, wherever you are ♫
♫ What are you doing in the bathroom? ♫
*instant shit bricks bruh*
FAGH YOU!
Oh, fuck off!
*grunt*
Alrighty, then!
Oooh!
GODDAMMIT, it's a mannequin.
How did I know?
"No idea what this thing is doing in here."
Well, I don't either.
Except
EXCLUSIVELY
for jumpscares...
Alright, then,
so that's how you're gonna be,
mmkay,
I see...
*reads*
Well, no need to be sorry about it, you-
Things are being spooped!
SPOOPED ALL OVER THE PLACE!
MAXIMUM SPOOPAGE
and I can't handle none of it...
NONE of it...
K...
Well that didn't do jack
diddly
SHIET.
Ah, here we go!
Key!
Got it!
Ok, so I got that key,
so I should be able to open the door
down here,
leading into the other corridor.
I wonder what awaits me...
Something gonna pop out at me?
HMM?
Anything?
Maybe?
Huh?
*undecipherable Mark noise*
Did somebody FART?
*high pitch squeal voice* Deeed somebody fart?
WOAH!
HELLOW!
Is that sum?
Is that a thi-
Is that a-
WHO THE FUCK
DO YOU THINK YOU-
uuuwweegghhh
Heyyy,
you runnin' away,
little
BITCH BABY?
Huh?! *random coughing*
*creeeaaaaakkkk*
Oh, I see how it is.
Ohh..
Oh, this is good.
Oh, hello.
Oh, hello. x2
♫ Come out, come out, wherever you are ♫
♫ Marky's gonna find you ♫
Oh, dammit.
Goddammit.
Oh, another heart!
Oh.
Agh, "This is horrible", apparently.
♫ Come out, come out ♫
Woah.
♫ Wherever you are ♫
♫ Marky's gonna find you ♫
♫ Come out, come out ♫
♫ Wherever you are ♫
Ahhhhhhh......goodie
But I didn't go down over here
It's so dark....did I miss something?
I must have missed something over here
"Boink"
Vacuum....
Secret found??
I don't know if it was much of a secret but I found it.
I don't know what's that going to do for me...
But I found a secret
Carrying on...
CARRYING OOOON~~
I don't know where we're gonna go now
Floor eight. Goddamn it.
Do I got to go all the way to Floor one?
All these identical floors....
*creak*
Huh...
*Creak* Ooh!
Oh! Well!
Somebody got dismombered
H'oh no! Someone lost an arm and a leg :(
All right so we got to find...
*reads*
Okay, as a general office worker,
how have you seen worse stuff than two legs
displayed out on your...floor?
Hello? *sharp inhale of marky breath*
Hi....how you doing?
Mhmmmmm
That's my thoughts exactly.
MhMMMMMM
Alright, you stay there then.
Fine. Fuck you.
I'll just carry on
Don't mind ---
Hello........
Good l-hehggguuuuu.
Alrighty then,
Oookay~
Oh God!
Why?
Can I get boob eyes back? (nervous laugh)
Appreciate her more than what you're doing...
(quietly) Alright. *creak*
Hellow
♫ Come out, come out
Whereve---
*wary voice* Fuck.....
I don't think they like me
singing that song
Ohhhh...
Ah!
Oooh. Hellow. *sniffle.* Mmm.
*reads*
I don't know if that's gonna happen. *Sniffle*
I have a funny feeling that's not gonna
happen.
*reads*
well that seems like a warning sign for
not being around here anymore
probably bleee. Okay, hello
*DIIING* well i'm not gonna go in that just yet
I got other places to explore first like
over *weird k noise* heyuhhh
dammit there's got to be a key to this. They wouldn't just put it here.
Oh
"Whatever walks there. I won't open this door"
Well shit ya big bubble blowing baby. Come on.
get some balls on ya. Alright, fine here we go.
Oh. Goodbye!
Uh-oh.
Hello?
Ooh...
hello
ummm...
*DING*
oh good I'm home free
let me just sprint towards my destiny
*loud noise*
oh, fuck you *girly screams*
FUCK OFF! I wanted to read that.
Ah, shit.
*Breathing and awkward/clenched butt cheeks silence*
there was a note on the ground
*DING* Oh..... OHHH okay..
*reads*
ok cool alrighty then
carrying on.
Let's not fell unconscious
anymore
Alright.
Jeez damn it.... Lawwwked
oh that's a comforting glow what do I
need that
Oh good, now i have that
how is that going to help me? Uh boy eh
boi yeah boi yeah boi
oh ok wait. Hang on a second what is going on
here whoa
eeuuggghhh something bad happend here or a
really good party maybe.
Found another secret for whatever that's worth
oh boy all right I'm out of here I had
enough top pine time dancing on the pile
of dead bodies all right let's carry on
over here havetyhup!
oh boy more I was hoping for more dead
bodies. OH BOY!
it's a smorgasbord whoa who threw
that?
who threw that? who's that-- who throws a
torzo? who does? come on now..
*DING* Oooh... That don't look good. Huh, maybe I'll avoid that for now
Maybe I'll go check out the other
areas before I walk into the elevator of
deaalth.
M'kay well let's go. What's the worst that
could happen?
everybody else seemed to have a good
time over here! hahauuhoho
floor seven god damn it how many floors
are there?
holy shit oh hey how's it going baby how
you doing baby
you're not gonna say anything about that
what did I just pick up I have no idea
what I got
well I got something alrighty then
*Phone ringing and other beep noises*
hello.
*more beeping/ringing noises*
Hello?
*Glass shatters*
Oh... Oh.....
Oh.....
I don't have a flash light anymore.
ooo... hello. hi. what happened to my flashlight??
oooooh okayy...
oh okay. What happened to my flashlight?
"Glowsticks never end"
"smartphone barely works" OOOHH
OH OKAY.
how did I get off of my flashlight what
the fuck happened
hoooly shit oh. Ahhhh fuck you!
Euh let me scribble a note real quick
I'm so fearful but i can write.
*Reads*
me neither bruh me nei-- ooooh hey whoa hey
alright fine then. Alright that's how
it's gonna be okay
goodbye goodbye goodbye
all right goodbye all right. God damn it is there a key in there that i didn't get? God..
damnuh
there we go give me that good bye
sayonara
eugh.
*banging on door*
*weird mark noises* no one's home. NO ONE'S HOME!
don't come knocking around here anymore.
Alright
ok blinking lights what a clishuh (cliche)
damn it locked door. heeyyy don't throw a box
did you throw this box
mr. dead lower body I'm coming for you
right. Great!
Who and why and how well that wasn't
there before
wow ok huh I'll go down. Why not?
AHH -- FUCK *sings* OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOFFFFFFFF
ok I think I scared him with my opera.
*Reads*
But you're not allowed to see it.
that'd be against the *rolls tongue* rrrrrrules
Hello?
hi no one here oh hey how's it going
friends
how you doin'? "They are completely
unmovable for some reason." Huh
well that's bizarre. Oh well.
*Reads*
well it's not like I had a choice no man
i did have a bed in there but I guess I
got to go out to eat eventually *sharp inhale*
♫ Come out, come out wherever you are. ♫
♫ Marky's gonna find you ♫
♫ Come out, come out--- ♫
Oh......
Oh, okay....
whoa what are you conferring about over
there
what are you doing? "I can feel weird
energy while standing near these
or maybe I'm just paranoid."
Noooo
I think there's some weird energy going on you
know if I had to guesstimate
apparently they moved from here dammit
BING! Okay. Oh hi, you're gonna join me on this
ride?
Oh shit ok door isn't concerning at all. Floor 6? Holy shit now i can only assume that
there's more floors to go for this but
I'm all out of time for this episode so
i'm going to assume that it has a
loading feature so we'll get to the rest
of this in another episode. I'll probably just
finish it out to the very end but I just
don't have any more time to record right
now so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always
I will see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!